o que é empreender significa o ato de
empreender porque nós empreendemos por
quem é lógico não existe uma resposta
certa para esse tipo de questionamento
mas é importante a gente ter consciência
das nossas respostas para mim
empreender é um ato revolucionário
eu sou engenheiro de formação mas não
sou necessariamente engenheiro de
vocação
trabalhei os 15 primeiros anos da minha
vida profissional na indústria
aeronáutica a oportunidade de trabalhar
certamente nas duas principais escolas
nesse setor
trabalhei na varig na segunda metade dos
anos 80 e trabalhei na embraer
durante os anos 90 a vocês que são
poucos mais novos na média do que eu
trabalhar na varig
nessa época significava mais ou menos
alguma coisa como trabalhar no google
diz
a varig talvez tenha sido a primeira
grande empresa verdadeiramente global do
nosso mercado o aparelho voava com
exclusividade a praticamente todos os
principais mercados os escritórios da
vaga era um praticamente embaixadas do
brasil que respondiam por serviços
diversos
a embraer nos anos 90 já exportava
aviões comerciais e aviões de defesa no
mundo todo
era o sonho de qualquer jovem engenheiro
nessas duas grandes corporações é era o
lugar ideal talvez para fazer uma
carreira por algum motivo em momentos
diversos
eu saí eu me demiti dessas empresas
na época não entendia muito bem mas
talvez eu tinha realmente ouvido uma
inquietude uma voz em uma mensagem
anterior
eu não queria uma carreira não queria
a uma carreira talvez eu fizesse alguma
coisa diferente talvez quisesse mesmo
será testar os meus limites e aí eu fui
empreender sair do mercado aeronáutico
time jogar como na aviação um espaço
vazio
o espaço vazio é um espaço que a gente
precisa conquistar um lugar aonde a
única certeza é o inseto agentes vão
vencer o terror do incerto a perceber
que esse também é um espaço da liberdade
isso pra mim em prender também é um ato
libertador
só que empreender dentro da nossa
cultura que rejeita de forma absoluta o
fracasso é um elemento a mais nesse
contexto nós temos medo de fracassar o
acordo fracassar o medo do fracasso faz
com que alguns empreendedores vir em
borda online transponham a barreira da
ética da moral e até do que é legal é um
medo de fracassar que fazer isso eu no
primeiro empreendimento que eu fiz como
como franqueado de uma marca americana
eu literalmente pra estava em
garopaba no verão de 99 quando william
bonner no jornal nacional veiculou a
notícia desastrosos
o real tinha sofrido uma
maxidesvalorização de 100%
nesse momento eu olhei para minha esposa
que está aqui grave da nossa segunda
filha que também está aqui disse
já quebrei não tinha outra solução
na verdade trabalhar com o fracasso é
muito difícil a gente tem é uma rejeição
muito grande e acaba fazendo qualquer
coisa então eu vivi esse drama durante
algum tempo mas ao mesmo tempo eu
percebi que era preciso encarar de
frente o fracasso
ao mesmo tempo eu percebi que eu estava
nessa administração do prejuízo fazendo
e adquirindo características que talvez
e certamente
levariam da coisas positivas no futuro
por exemplo nos novos negócios
eu acabei percebendo que o fracasso ele
acaba criando uma resiliência muito
maior
e foi assim que aconteceu e aí eu
percebi uma coisa básica nesse processo
de empreender se deu errado eo errado a
gente na verdade tem muita dificuldade
de conviver com ele
uma pesquisa recente da deloite
pesquisando 23 mil profissionais de
diferentes mercados viu que 82 por cento
desses profissionais tem nem na questão
do estresse no trabalho principal
elemento para eles a questão do estresse
no trabalho é um medo de errar a gente
cresce ouvindo que errar é humano mas
certamente muitos de vocês vivem de
segunda a sexta-feira da manhã à noite
em espaços onde errar é absolutamente
desumano e de alguma forma cria-se
stress e oprime no ao longo do dos do
tempo a gente foi vendo que é muito
difícil criar uma condição onde uma
pessoa só reúna todas as qualidades
necessárias para desenvolver uma
atividade qualquer para construir um
negócio
ninguém consegue juntar todas as
competências habilidades e atitudes
necessárias para isso
então a gente caminha uma visão de que
realmente nós somos seres incompletos
por isso erramos por isso a gente é
existe uma outra coisa que a gente
precisa combater na atitude de
empreender é existe uma cultura que a
gente vive uma cultura ocidental
o empreendedor super herói do self-made
né
na verdade esse empreendedor super herói
eu não sei onde ele está eu faria com
vocês uma rápida reflexão pense agora
na maior conquista da vida de vocês pode
ser uma conquista profissional pode ser
uma conquista no esporte que você
praticou prática pode ser uma conquista
na sua formação
qualquer conquista
eu pergunto vocês estavam sozinhos
garanto que não não existe conquista não
existe grande conquista individual
ninguém consegue realizar nada
expressivo sozinho na verdade não existe
um super-herói nessa história de
quadrinhos até porque no mundo moderno
existe mais quadrinhos na então gente a
gente tem que entender que empreender é
também com um ato coletivo é
essencialmente um ato coletivo
se a gente pegar esses primeiros minutos
eu falei a gente considerar a primeira
essa história do espaço vazio que é um
espaço não só do pânico do terror mas é
um espaço de liberdade somar com isso
essa visão de que errar é absolutamente
humano faz parte de um processo
um processo que tem na sua base
aprendizagem e juntar isso com uma ação
coletiva
certamente a gente se projeta como
empreendedor para a atmosfera que são
inovadoras
há quase 20 anos atrás eu decidi que eu
empreender no universo digital
o ambiente digital foi escolhido não foi
por acaso o ambiente digital é um
ambiente limpo ambiente democrático é um
ambiente absolutamente universal é um
ambiente
o transformador o ambiente digital é na
verdade talvez aí o esteio dessa
sociedade em rede que o castells fala é
um pilar de toda essa discussão da
modernidade líquida dos tempos líquidos
do baú é na verdade o ambiente digital é
basicamente o state toda essa discussão
nova sobre o pensamento contemporâneo
quando eu decidi junto com os meus
sócios montar uma agência na ativa do
digital
a gente decidiu trabalhar muito na
contracultura da propaganda e da
comunicação
em poucos anos o empreendimento que a
gente fez ganhou uma dimensão muito
grande muito maior do que a gente
pensava passou a ser uma referência
dentro da comunicação digital como mar
em 2010 foi adquirida por um grande
grupo de comunicação na verdade terceiro
maior grupo de comunicação do mundo
eu talvez na minha ingenuidade achava
que todos esses elementos não é que
trazem essa minha visão é de um jeito de
empreender um dos meus sócios vão
transformar essa cultura de um grande
grupo de comunicação internacional
eu queria na verdade olhar de dentro da
baleia e quem sabe transformar a baleia
mas mais uma vez eu me enganei
é muito difícil falar em transformação
de cultura organizacional e quando a
gente viu mais do que uma dificuldade de
transformar aquela grande organização
que havia adquirido a gente muito antes
pelo contrário a gente ia passar por um
processo de transformação da nossa
cultura ea ser profundamente
transformado por aquela cultura maior
que tínhamos adquiridos no início nem a
nossa agência
ela era muito retrato daquilo que nós
éramos mas em seguida ela passou a ser
mais uma unidade de negócio de uns
milhares de agências espalhadas pelo
mundo e que na verdade traziam uma
relação absolutamente pessoal com todos
e com todos os processos e sem perceber
embora tivesse
valores muito interessantes e muito
respeitosos desumaniza vá toda relação
aí eu tomei mais uma decisão dentro
dessa lembrando a minha as decisões na
varig na praia
eu pedi demissão da agência da empresa
que eu mesmo havia criado
eu decidi que eu queria resgatar alguns
valores importantes na minha relação com
essa visão de empreender
eu queria na verdade poder olhar uma
funcionária grávida e projetar nela uma
mulher completa completa uma mãe se
formando em ficar muito feliz com isso
sem precisar fazer contas e pensar
quanto vai custar a licença maternidade
queria também não precisar nunca mais na
minha vida
pedi para um pai de um filho de poucas
semanas
passar o feriadão toda a agência só
porque uma concorrência é importante
na verdade eu fui novamente empreender a
tentar resgatar a minha visão é o meu
propósito empreender e buscar o seu
propósito pessoal precisa querer
encontrar eu comecei a encontrar o meu
quando eu pedi demissão da varig quando
pedi demissão na embraer
quando eu fracassei no primeiro negócio
quando pedi demissão de novo da agência
que eu havia construído
talvez o meu propósito pessoal seja
realmente construir projetos inovadores
uma visão coletiva e humana
mas eu gosto de pensar que mais que o
propósito pessoal é importante que a
gente conheça qual é o nosso objeto
social como qualquer das empresas que a
gente cria um constrói toda empresa tem
um contrato social
esse contrato social é uma concessão da
sociedade para que a gente entregue para
a sociedade mais do que ela dá pra nós e
no primeiro parágrafo desse objeto desse
contrato social tem o objeto social
o objeto social talvez vocês não tenham
se dado conta podia ser chamados copo de
qualquer outra coisa mas na verdade não
é a tarefas funções da empresa faz toda
intervenção de uma empresa na sociedade
tem um impacto social se essa empresa
contrata pessoas e paga salários se paga
impostos e se produz desenvolve ou
contrata tecnologias isso tem um impacto
social
o meu objeto objeto social
talvez seja o que estou fazendo aqui com
vocês tentar ressignificar o ato de
empreender
quando a gente construiu a nossa agência
lá quase 18 19 anos atrás a gente tinha
três coisas importantes
uma visão e um valor muito grande pra
voz coletiva um respeito muito grande
pela iniciativa a possibilidade de
representar bem os talentos individuais
e uma valorização da visão empreendedora
não interessa de quem fosse o primeiro
valor quando nós criamos norteadores da
empresa era acreditar nas pessoas e no
conhecimento das pessoas pois bem
vários profissionais que passaram pela
nossa agência
eu já não sou mais o senhor vários
passos profissionais que passaram por lá
construíram as suas empresas se tornaram
empreendedores e hoje fazem muito
sucesso
muitos deles nesse mercado da
comunicação
eu gosto muito mais de enxergar que eu
construir talvez aí uma escola de
empreender de empreendedores dentro da
comunicação digital do que uma marca
a realizadora de serviços é diferenciada
nesse ambiente da comunicação digital eu
jamais tive qualquer problema de um
empreendedor ou de uma pessoa que passou
de fosse um colaborador nós chegar pra
mim pedir demissão dizendo que
empreender na verdade de alguma forma
talvez o nome é voltasse e reto projetar
se lembrando os tempos de várias praias
é que o empreender era fundamental para
aquelas pessoas que tinham essa atitude
empreendedora
depois que eu saí da função disse ouda
agência ontem mais seis negócios
diferentes todos eles com essa visão e
com empreendedores que entendem essa
visão é inovadora coletiva e humana
hoje são 6 negócios que trabalham quase
como um ecossistema de inovação algumas
sinergias pontos na área da comunicação
mas voltados ao design conteúdo mídia
adaptações serviço de uma forma geral se
eu falhar e se nesses seis
empreendimentos não mais um
como já disse paciência né
deu errado mas se por acaso tiver
sucesso em tudo for bem talvez eu
consiga realmente ressignificar pra mim
essa visão do empreender
talvez agora uma forma multiplicado
provavelmente na nesse momento se tudo
dá certo
isso vai ser um ato libertador
vai ser um ato coletivo e certamente vai
ser um ato humano provavelmente pra mim
uma revolução espero que pra mim e para
todos nós
obrigado
[Aplausos]